a new report suggests the FBI was slow
to pursue former USA women's gymnastics
dr. Larry Nasser while he molested
patients the New York Times reports he
abused at least 40 girls and women for
more than a year after a federal
investigation began NASA's latest
sentencing hearing resumes today our dr.
Jon LaPook has been following the story
John good morning good morning Nora the
report shows FBI agents were disgusted
by videos of NASA demonstrating his
techniques including one in which he
reached between girl's legs to perform
what he called the hand shaky thing the
report also gives new insight into why
it took so long to stop him from using
that medical cover to molest young
athletes USA Gymnastics says it first
told the FBI about Nasser's abuse in
July 2015 informing them of allegations
against Larry Nasser and giving them
contact information for three elite
athletes including Maggie Nichols why
didn't the authorities contact us until
a year later
Gina Nichols is Maggie's mother she told
CBS News last month that an FBI agent
did not reach out until June of 2016 and
I asked him why did it take him so long
to contact me when I reported this a
year ago and he said he just got this
assignment the day before the New York
Times reports some of the delay appears
to have been related to questions
concerning federal versus state
jurisdiction as well as jurisdiction
within the FBI itself I have questions
about whether the FBI had any
jurisdiction to begin an investigation
Ron Hosko a former FBI assistant
director and CBS News consultant says
sexual assault cases are typically
handled by local police did the FBI in
some way have discreet information that
nobody else had and do nothing with it
that's problematic and I'm sure they're
looking at that anger boiled over last
week at NASA's latest sentencing hearing
Randel margrave's father of three
victims sought to impose his own justice
I did not think about wanting to kill
him but I did want to inflict some pain
the judge said she wouldn't punish the
father for being in contempt of court
meanwhile the FBI released the statement
saying the magnitude of allegations
brought against mr. Nasser transcended
jurisdictions and we worked with our law
enforcement partners to identify the
relevant information that pertained to
violations of federal and state laws
what have you learned John about what
the FBI told USA Gymnastics during this
whole investigation USA Gymnastics has
said that the reason why they didn't
alert Michigan State about Nasser's
abuse was that the FBI had said in July
of 2015
don't do anything to interfere with our
investigation they took that to mean
don't contact in organizations like
Michigan State but when I spoke to
Maggie Nichols mother she said when the
FBI finally reached out to Maggie that
the FBI agent said you can tell anybody
you want you can talk to anybody you
want so there are questions that remain
interesting reporting thanks John
all right thanks John